RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S #HASHTAGWARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WE JUST SHOWED YOU FOOTAGE OF AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PRINCIPAL
INFORMING HIS STUDENTS THAT
SCHOOL IS BEING CLOSED BY
RAPPING TO "ICE ICE BABY," WHICH
GAVE US THE IDEA FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS: #FROZENBANDS.
#FROZENBANDS.
EXAMPLES WOULD BE:
"CHILLY VANILI."
"NEGATIVE 98 DEGREES."
"MIAMI SNOCONE MACHINE."
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK, AND GO.
BRAUNGER.
>> SNOW-ASIS!
>> Chris: POINTS!
YES, RON.
>> QUEENS OF THE ICE AGE.
Chris: POINTS!
APARNA?
>> AC/AC.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS, POINTS.
RON?
>> FROZEN TO DEATH LEPPARD.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
APARNA.
>> DEPECHE À LA MODE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
OH, TAKING IT DESSERT-Y.
YES, BRAUNGER.
>> FREE-Z TOP.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
RON?
>> I.C.P, THAT'S ICE CREAM
POSSE.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: APARNA?
>> RADIO WALT DISNEY'S HEAD.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OH, BECAUSE IT'S
FROZEN!
OH MY GOD, POINTS.